hey guys Ryan right so the daredevil
adventure continues I am on episode 4s
right now just finish it holy [ __ ] I
know I'm taking my time with this show
because each episode is like a movie so
I like to absorb each episode and let it
sink it's a my subconscious so I could
be more creative [ __ ] love this show
right from the opening of that this
episode talk about brutality I love the
guy who plays the villain of this
episode I don't remember the guys name
but he's bald looks red-headed Irish
sort of looking anyway yeah he fights
the mob boss at the beginning and he
totally just annihilates them cuz he
wants to go bowling and then he oh man
the brutality snaps that guy's arm the
bone cross out he beats the guy's head
into the bowling ball holy [ __ ] I have
never seen a show that has that brutal
of an opening and stylistic at the same
[ __ ] time and then it cuts to the
priest and Matt Murdock talking I like
that scene actually they don't go back
to it but you can tell the priest is
like hey I kind of know that you're this
vigilante but because we're in
confession I can't say anything but if
we have a cup of coffee outside a
confession and you confessed to me I
could report it to the police so I like
how Matt Murdock is smart about it how
I'll keep going to confession he's not
gonna hang out with the priest outside
of confession they introduced me Ben I
think is his name he's the journalist
who wants to report on the news when the
news was the news I like how they
compare how everything is now
internet-based it's all social media
based and he's like an old-school
journalist who wants to find the good
news stories and that was a great scene
when kingpins guy James is his name and
when James decides to go meet up with
Matt Murdock and foggy and asked them to
be his lawyers that was really cool I
love how it all connected it made sense
for them to go to Matt Murdock to go to
their law firm because they're just
up-and-coming rather than going to
people who are already well-known they
can start it's like kind of I think of
like when you initiate a kid into a gang
like you start off when they're young
and
you can just you know corrupt their mind
over time that's kind of like what I
thought they were trying to do with them
start them off when they're young still
fresh in the law firm but get them
involved in the bad guy business up
front
I love how Matt becomes suspicious of
him it's so cool because the crime
lawyer stuff is just as good as the
stuff where he's daredevil and it all
connects perfectly but then when Matt
Murdock decides to take on the client
he's taking on the client that I saw at
the beginning of the episode because I
want to get him out of jail
fantastic [ __ ] scene I love him and
Matt Murdock's interaction because that
bad guy is so [ __ ] good his acting is
amazing he's so sincere and you could
see why people might believe his side of
the story because he doesn't play it
like I'm a sinister guy who has an evil
secret about myself he plays it like a
real human being but he gives those nice
hints letting Matt know hey I'm actually
in control of situation I like where the
story's going with Karen how she was
offered money to keep her mouth shut
about everything that went on and then
she goes to see the wife of the man who
died in her apartment that was a really
good scene because you see that she
caved in and it gives Karen an
opportunity to be like you know what I
could just cave in to accept all the
money if this person's wife is willing
to let this secret just go with her she
can do it too but you could see that
there's a story building with her where
it's a chance of redemption and doing
the right thing seriously like all this
stuff with long order is fantastic when
he's able to pick up on that there's
someone in the jury who is you know
probably being corrupted or threatened
to plead up this guy's innocent I really
like how they switch that person out how
daredevil is able to switch that person
out the speech he gives about just
laying out the truth like he's still
being a lawyer sort of defending his
client that he knows is wrong and he
wants the guy to be incarcerated but he
gives a speech of truth that is not
necessarily defending the lawyer nor is
it necessarily opposing the lawyer it's
just all about truth and facts and then
of course the guy goes that was a great
fight scene between him and daredevil
that opening fight is great because it
really is
step I love the violence in it because
it really establishes just how
threatening and how brutal this villain
is how he can actually be an opposing
threat to daredevil to Matt Murdock so
they had a great fight scene I love when
he reveals that it's Wilson Fisk I love
that moment because then the guy just
[ __ ] kills himself afterwards through
this spike and he just hits his head on
it which I love because it's sure it's
really violent I don't love it just
because it's violent I love it because
it's a brutal way to kill yourself but
he was saying like this Wilson Fisk guy
is gonna go after everyone that I love
and so he'll do whatever it takes to
kill himself right then and there
showing just how [ __ ] scary
Wilson Fisk is the way they're building
up kingpin is brilliant I love how they
gave such a unique touch to introducing
Wilson Fisk word is looking at the
painting and he says that a painting
makes him feel lonely it's so different
than what you might expect for an
introduction of this kind of criminal
mastermind how he's someone who is like
depressed and sad you know he has like a
feeling of emptiness and you pick up on
all that because Vincent D'Onofrio I
think is his name he's such a good actor
he transforms into characters he gets
like a couple of lines at the end of
this episode but man do you get a good
grasp of the depth that he has provided
for this character I'm excited to
continue this show daredevil [ __ ]
rocks if you're new to the channel you
can subscribe to the real rejects and
you can follow us on Facebook Instagram
and Twitter where I'm constantly posting
pictures of what have I not covered yet
my butthole I post pictures on my
butthole